in the lobby of Ramsey solutions Chris
and Rozier with us is it Rossi what is
it Rosie okay all right Zach can't spell
that's the problem okay just an unusual
spelling yeah okay well they spelled it
right and I'm the one that's a doofus
okay welcome guys where do y'all live we
live in Fort Bragg Oh military yes sir
well thank you for your service we
appreciate it so here to do your debt
free scream yes sir I love it how much
of you paid off
thirty thousand eight hundred and
seventy three dollars I love it and how
long did that take we started in October
2013 and we paid off in August as in
this month Wow
way to go so we got me see here 13 to 14
so here in 10 months a year in ten
months thank you okay so all right there
we good good and that took out and
making what kind of money during that
time ah well being in the military I
bring in about thirty two thousand a
year while I'm deployed I bring in
upwards of forty two mm-hmm okay so 32
to 42 you did this that's pretty amazing
it actually he do to him coming back
from deployment he actually is only
making around 36 now and so we've only
had that income to pay this off and
that's pretty incredible that you did
that and so kind of Rosie did this while
you were gone pretty much yeah yeah he's
gone from November you're connecting
whether I guess by email or whatever if
you can and that kind of stuff we did
Skype more often than anything okay very
good good so what kind of debt was the
31,000 well we had 18,000 on a car that
my younger self thought was a brilliant
idea to buy brand new and every one of
us had that younger self I don't know
what happened to that guy yeah and the
rest of it was in credit cards okay so
what did you do with said stupid car we
still have it and we actually drove all
the way from here in that car oh you got
it paid for we paid it off Wow I was
thinking with that income and that debt
you must have sold it oh my goodness no
it was the last that we paid off you
have been on be
and rice for sure yes sir I mean
absolutely no room in this budget oh my
goodness that's impressive how did you
do I mean in two years you did 31,000
making 35,000 and on top of that we had
ten grand in dental bills for my lovely
wife here and we cash flowed all of that
and also cash flowed across country move
okay we are you're living on base yes
sir okay that helped the math a bunch
okay cuz I'm you just you had no money
left it was just like in the Running
Room in that math okay now I got it
but yeah you don't have any housing or
utility or insurance expense we get a
paycheck from our utilities because I
make sure that all the lights get turned
off and and we get somewhere between 70
and $20 a month just from living in the
dark yeah yeah the energy the heat
turned up at appropriate levels these
lights which not see Wow I love it you
guys are great
this is incredible I mean if you can do
this you can do anything you know that
this is very impressive the level of
detail and the level of commitment and
discipline for two years here's pretty
stinking strong that's amazing so what
started the journey tell me what
happened one year and ten months ago
that's that flipped the switch and made
this whole thing go sideways it actually
happened a bit before then during the
housing market collapse in the early
2000s my parents went through a pretty
serious bankruptcy and that got me
thinking about debt but I still held on
to the idea that oh yeah we can pay off
the credit card at the end of the month
until it started building up and
building up to a level that started me
feeling very uncomfortable with it and
then I pretty much said I don't want to
live this way and I've always I was
apparently one of the few people that
actually got taught by their parents to
do a budget and finally I said this is
not acceptable and we're changing it
mm-hmm
he was like yeah that sounds like a good
idea yeah okay and then of course her
mom's friend found your book the Total
Money Makeover pass it off to her mom
and we have that same copy here in the
lobby with us oh wow we're hoping to get
signed and sent back to them okay be
assured that will happen at the break
that's awesome man
very cool so I hand me down book yes sir
love it that's that's the best kind
you guys just spend money on anything I
mean that's amazing
so when you hear when you know people
sometimes say Dave I really people call
your show you know they don't make
$120,000 a year of course they can get
out of debt
you guys make thirty five thousand
dollars a year you paid off thirty-one
thousand dollars in it in less than two
years how did you do that tell people
what was the what's the key points the
key principles that allowed you to do
that focus and intensity and she kept me
honest I just honestly having him
overseas also helped because I though he
was involved in the budget I could live
on very little you know there was only
me eating there was only me living in
the house and only you to control right
overseas I gave myself a $50 month
allowance to buy sodas and other random
stuff that I wanted and kept it at that
and of course I sent him care packages
as much as I could and did those sorts
of crazy stuff very cool way to go you
guys so the the accountability the
communication you were working very
closely in sync obviously and the the
extreme frugality is what it amounts to
you just really you just turn off the
lights I mean that's it and we're gonna
do this so uh Chris what is your job in
the military what are you doing which
branch I'm in military intelligence now
initially I spent nine years in the
infantry and said that's enough that and
switched over to military intelligence
with and while I was in the military
intelligence school is when we decided
to get our life back on track
okay all right very cool and then and so
this last deployment was in that area
yes sir okay well I won't have to do
anything else okay that's good but
you're you're obviously army right yes
sir okay good okay fine
well congratulations and thank you for
your service you guys are incredible
sharp sharp young couple I promise you
you can do this you can do anything
there is something else I had a lot of
support from my mom she definitely kept
me honest and one of my friends here and
well up there in Fort Bragg having that
good support group we'd really also made
it you know they were pushing me to do
it and keep things you know within the
budget all right so what's mom's name
mom is Lisa and the friend and Ashley is
my friend awesome give them both a
shout-out then that's perfect good well
way to go because you can't you know you
got to have people around you it's
that's that's why we have the small
group discussion and Financial Peace
University is the accountability and the
encouragement and so well
congratulations you too I'm proud to
know you I'm proud you're serving your
country and we we're glad we had a small
part of helping you as you became
rockstars or turning your life around
way to go all right Chris and Rosie Fort
Bragg North Carolina here we go baby
$31,000 paid off in 22 months making
thirty two to forty two thousand dollars
during that time count it down let's
hear a debt free scream three two one
is how it's done
oh man I love it congratulations you two
and that's that's just very cool